the feds
were interested in taking down
the whole mafia
i'm just one more guy putting a piece of
the puzzle together for him
this special agent was gonna be my
handler he gave me the small recorder
and it went into a jock strap and he's
like yeah just put it on over your
underwear you have to record everybody
there's no exceptions
he started going over rules can't leave
the wire no violence
none at all
otherwise the deal's off
he gave me my code name
brake shot
brake shot is the
first shot in a pool game when they
spread out all the balls and that's
basically what they wanted me to do to
help smash them off into pieces
[Music]
the deal was
six months to a year but i knew my life
was about to change forever
the first time i was wearing a wire
i was going to meet a cappo named jimmy
kacchi a very powerful captain in the
columbo family
contrary to popular belief there's no
agents waiting in a van around the
corner
when i press the button
i realized that
i was about to go out and i'm going to
record
one of the most dangerous men in the
world
i thought in my head this is it this is
this is for real
[Music]
where in a wire you think that everyone
can see that thing in your pocket
hey kenji how you doing
i sit down the table
so tell me how's the business this woman
is always sad
and in walks this
big italian guy who i've never seen
before
he identified on tape he said i'm a wise
guy just like jimmy
he starts talking about the inner
workings of the mafia he wants to
propose a guy
into the organization from vegas
and i'm just sitting there still
hoping that the recorder is picking up
every word because i know it's
he's a friend good he talked about the
organization as structure and this is
what the fbi is after this is the kind
of evidence that they want
and then i start to feel this warm
sensation coming from the recorder
but i just kind of blow it off
because
the guy's it's talking a lot i want to
let things unfold
all right
yeah what they might be up to apparently
they're not going after us
and i'm looking at him and it's starting
to get hotter and hotter and hotter and
hotter
i'm realizing that this thing is
starting to burn in my crotch
you okay
[Music]
all of a sudden it just gets unbearable
finally i just told him
i gotta go
[Music]
i met up with my handler
she asked me so what happened
i told him
it was burning so hot i thought my nuts
were on fire
just started laughing
he's like oh i heard that sometimes they
malfunction like that
but i was relieved because he told me
that the tape was good
it was valuable because it would help
them find the structure and figure out
who's doing what
as time went on
i started to get it down
i learned how to elicit what i wanted
other people your business you bring it
to me i get it done
another drink over here
but
the fear never goes
you always have to worry about being
found out
almost every single person i knew
had been involved in a murder at one
point or another
and i was gathering intel on them for
the fbi
i started seeing that it could actually
make a difference
i'm gonna need some fake id's guns
bulletproof vests
that encouraged me to do more because i
felt like i accomplished something raise
it to five at this point i've been
undercover for six months i was supposed
to be wearing a wire
but i decided to continue on
because i began to feel
a lot of pride in what i was doing
[Music]
the fbi wanted me to aim higher
go bigger and
i knew that that meant the new york
families
it's the epicenter of the mafia it's
where the power is
so i made a trip to new york
that's when i met eddie garfollow
[Music]
good to meet you
a lot about you
eddie garafolo was a colombo associate
from new york
and he was very well connected
jerry believes in you i guess you're the
real deal
and he wanted me to move to brooklyn
and be in in his crew
and being invited there was a huge step
up
this was my chance to get intel on the
real big fish in the mafia
i'm honored truly
but i had no idea what i was getting
myself into
[Music]
you